this video is sponsored by one of my personal
favorite Services rocket money more on them
after the reaction [Music] people hello there
citizens of the reject Nation after loving the
last episode for Monarch I'm excited to see
what's in store for the finale after that
Cliffhanger John are you ready to get your canar
on I can't wait GE that's what I'm talking about
Kon canaro um that was the greatest thing I
don't care who didn't like that intro last
episode that was the best intro ever anyway guys
uh for listen Apple Spotify thank you for being
here and uh if you are stick through this intro
cuz I'm going to say leave a like on this video
for our YouTube viewers also uh subscribe click
the notification Bell for other Jazz stuff that
comes up here that's a terminology thank you to
prepper for helping us Ed down these highlights
and the fooling through at your watch Al single
with your own copy of mon that is available for
a super sexy rejects over at our patreon
page thank you so much to everyone who has
joined us for Monarch and all the other shows
John and I cover several things exclusively
over there with highlights and watch songs
included John yes let's get it Shan let's do
[Music]
it who are you all right I can't really
answer that right now can you walk have
you fired a boat before those creatures are
very Territorial and we are in their territory
now yep good ready that's how that [__]
Works were you expecting someone else I wasn't
expecting to be alive you're in heaven what's
your name I'm Kate and my brother's canar you
may have heard our theme song we fell my God
me we have to find the people I came with is
Billy with you Bill Randa we have to find them we
will calm down I mean you might find Sha this way
did you listen to what she asked you yeah
did you hear did question Kate did you pay
attention to access to Hollow Earth
damn dude working right against
Lea something he
rejected it's true that's why I had
two families it was all part of my
plan Maps
good luck with that we've been chipping away
at that block for centuries cuff him Shake him
away what a great way to avoid a
question it's a wonderful Monarch CLA it's
a live again I mean you're a terrible father
Yes like you're just a a really bad dad rest of
your rescue party follow my beacon there's only
one place they can come out I've been down
here for 2 weeks yeah don't to be an Archer
what signal you're not part of a rescue party are
you you didn't expect to find me here you don't
even know who I am you're an not Monarch
who are you I'm [Music] Miranda oh my God
God yes come on make it official he is that
really you of course it is did they get Wyatt
Russell do the voice there sounded like
him it's me K it's Lee right behind this
tree come out where I can see you no no
just stay stay there for a second oh a
there's some things you need to understand how
long do you think you've been down here okay
40 minutes my estimation 57 days days yes how
much time passes per day I came down here too
okay after you fell I let a recon mission
you were here how you didn't tell me came
down here in 1962 I thought I was here for
only a week or so and then I was able to get
right back up I escaped it was 1982 that was
a week back then that was 33 33 years ago oh
wow man she is so good I love her she's great
MVP aside from the mom oh the gravitational
Distortion some Waring of space the realization
is it 2015 great math yeah she's a scientist
you always work good with numbers K oh
oh hope she looks disgusted you're old
e old [Laughter] guy I can't believe you're
alive oh [Music] oh that's tragic Billy he's
he's gone he died a long time ago man this
is a scene this is tragic there has never
been so much emotion in a monster vers
first movie you're lying my wife died
here oh he's doing fine he's by me how do you know
how do you know how do you
know who are you I'm your
[Music] granddaughter wow what a weird matter
of processing is how to do in the what a mix
of emot 30 seconds Jesus yeah she's she's a
terrif good Tim Tim what about the signal it
is not our priority right now some someone
could be alive and that is not a priority my
man we are looking at a wave of Titan events
threatening the lives of 7 billion people I'm
not peeling off resources to save three that guy
just looked over like a [__] this was a steak
someone is alive down there and they might have
the answers we need and they are calling us for
help we cannot pretend that we don't hear him
like I see a Tim look at the map of Tim Tim my
hands are tied then untie them oh otherwise Shaw
was right about us he was definitely right about
you oh how Monarch went from corrupt to good
I need you to think very carefully about the
next words you're going to say are you going to
take your seat do your job and help us deal with
this crisis nah unbelievable I reconfigured the
EM tube to send out a directional gamap pul to
that you know where I was so monarch made it to
1962 they're around even today bigger than ever
that was part of it oh that's not happy news it
is now 20145 yeah we're going to get back into a
whole different version of life and Society tell
me about him he's a a family man he's a familyes
man when Monarch wouldn't let him he did it
on his own he never knew when to stop except
when to stop being a dad can you rewire this
back to its original configuration I think so
in that case I'm going to take you home yeah how
so I'm going to carry you over the threshold she
wouldn't have been able to figure that out herself
yeah I don't know that's a seems like she would V
one oh damn he's moving
out
ouch in such a polite [Music] way
MVP in it man I will give him money
yes and I'll call on his birthday
maybe keep me out of
it now I got to start up a whole new
second family he married both yes you
know jurisdictions different damn it you would
need four people to carry it though we can all
use a breather works for me man Wyatt and Kurt
had to fall in love with the same woman I know
hey seriously don't go far ah they're so
alike it's a call back they're meant to
be that's where that's first oh what the the meat
cutees can tar would have heard him be
let in apparently like do like a whole
callbo thing to do it he's just so wrapped
up in his drawing not uh not usually a big
whiskey guys what are you doing here oh come
on the Gamay bursts we found the coherent
signal what am I supposed to do with it I
don't know what what any of this means no
you don't what your bloodline does but your
father might yeah do you know where we might
find him now okay I got to tell you you look
exactly as you've always looked in my mind's
eye why aren't you happy come on give us a kiss
love I've been talking to you and Billy in my head
the whole time I was here who you were anyway
way oh she's studying his face what happened
to Billy gained some weight turn into John good I
guess he was leading an expedition to some Island
and name the island trying to prove some of the
theories about all this and uh he he never came
back he died unceremoniously oh [__] yes and
we've been trying to make up for that ever since
but he did it K he was the last man standing
he saved Monarch he saved everything you and
he built everything the three of us built a
you were always the Third Wheel Lee yeah a
man that is hard I love how they're having two
very different experiences I've lost so much
time Lee worst 57 odd days 58 days what's it like
now 2015 even the words sound fantastic fantastic
yeah coming out of the 1950s jeez yeah cars are
smaller more efficient nowhere near is cool TV
sets are bigger fat oh hey we went to the moon of
course I missed that one too because I was down
here but you know same old world it ain't you
babe same people conflicts triumphs damn Kurt
Russell's been killing it you know moms dads
kids he didn't get to have any of that either
yeah oh way she looks at him man well speaking
of kids I guess I should check in on ours huh
ours you may never forgive me for what I took
from you and I can't go back in time and fix
all the mistakes I made but maybe I could
leave something for the future a legacy of
monsters Tim what are you doing here
can we come in reveal yes and I have
no interest in working with monac that's
probably good because they wouldn't touch
you with a 10-ft pole Gamay bursts coming
from inside the Rifts I'm well aware of
gamma emissions not these hey there is
a coherent signal in there s o s how by
what by who he thinks Kate could be alive
I I mean Grandma it's impossible it's not
impossible Shaw came back and the rest of
the team didn't the variables are nearly
infinite yeah Fair quit delaying this come on
we're on the final freaking episode go hosi come
on you said you wanted me to work with you fine
I'm in but first help me find my sister to be a
family yeah we can all go live in San Francisco
now Monarch won't help no with something like this
they won't and that's why I quit oh Monarch isn't
the only game in town I work for Apex now why does
it look so much like Earth because it is parts
are It Anyway different pieces of Home different
pieces of their world the last the most of the
Season feel like these last two episodes yeah I
know axis Monday p and have any Earth no ax Mundy
or did we enter the r at home but welcome to it
Alice wow we're almost there let's keep moving
but you're still contained within something
science this is Hall earth right i' unless they're
just going to surprise us with another another
realm inside the Earth yeah cuz I feel like this
Journey has been about how they've been able to
access Hollow Earth yeah that is our ride come
on let's go they're in love she looks like she
doesn't want to go back yeah she doesn't want
to have to age got to be kidding me hey this
is amazing isn't it it's only been a few days 53
years and it still got juice it's only been here
a few weeks yeah all right let's get these things
wired up and get the hell out of here you've got
more pep in your step than when you were younger
yeah I got it I know how to finish it I've got
this hey stop I've got this hey what is wrong
with I'm staying behind why oh yeah Billy's
gone my boy cor up without me I am not going
to BR his life again by reappearing suddenly uh
well what's wrong with this family I know just
just go be together Christ these monsters have
taken everything from me no more this curse
is broken you still have work to do up there
this show is dictating its Arc yes and we need
you we need you for Godzilla X Kong eventually
wish Kate would acknowledge that that's I mean um
what Mo and get out of here Grand okay okay yeah
exactly Grand like you're talking about your
son but yo you're granddaughter's right here
right in front of you dude I know you just met
but also I'm assuming this flight doesn't have
drink service nope but when we get back first
round's on me huh going to counter Godzilla
trying to prevent them kind of seems like old
times huh straight for yourself let's go home
I love the contrast of their performances just
makes so much sense that they have two different
experiences it's very multi-layer best scene work
of the entire show that thing starts blipping it
means the device is lur a Titan that'll open the
the rift and that's our way home but how do we
take off just hang on this taller wiard hits
3,000 ft I'll shut the device off the Titans
Retreat will pull us in there he is what
if they all die right now what do you see
a [__] we leared a Titan that was already
here where's Godzilla yeah fight Let Them
Fight give me my big lizard come on this be
the first time CT Sees God so what do we do
running out of time and we're not going to
get another shot keep ringing that dinner
bell help them out goira o
yeah no someone's got to go out there it's leaving
it's going away from us [__] what are
you doing my job yeah Dam it no no no no
no what are you doing punch it
in the face this would be such a
[Music] bummer oh my God come on
come on come on Doc yeah come on
Doc come on get that lightning
strike easy he get back
here feel like uh setting up the wires to be
that taut was probably not a great
choice when you were arranging all
this that is scary come on man that is really
scary where to go Doc Brown come
on goir where are
you here we go come on come
on great shot that shot Kur
Russell must have sent a signal
to Callum that looks like yeah
Oh shot D that's a great shot nice oh
cool that's great get out of my house get off
my lawn oh my God we're getting a Kaiu fight
you had to do it oh my God nice camera too oh damn
sweet oh and the glowing eyes oh e that's my trick
man oh great yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
oo oh oh my what is that going
to do it like a Vortex within a
Vortex get in there come on Lee God
damn it please no this would suck so
much come on T this would suck so much
no come on pull him too much uh for
[Music] [Applause]
everything that's a real bummer
yeah after she just lost everything St in outside
of her granddaughter and Son yes don't worry we'll
have to come back here for him in season two make
eye contact it's great shot out the bar [Music]
[Music]
[Music] Point why am I not liking the vibe here
yeah I mean cuz this is obviously
some kind of containment and or
[Music] observation wow we've
waited decades for something
exciting to happen right yeah we had this
helipad built and we didn't even know what
for oh and I thought it was just
like the same people they maybe
it's Apex you did all this me no I
don't understand most of them but
we were lucky someone had already done
a lot of the math you freaking me now
daddy
dad a he thought you were
dead break down man go to her wow he's
older than her now [Music] yeah that
is sad [Music] that happens oh she's she
is so good yeah she's the best one she is
the MVP oh look at him me cradle like
a boy it's so it's like so mother and
son you know being Asian myself I'm always
being told Asian moms aren't that expressive
and emotional but I see two very emotional moms
in this show it's true canaro I'd like you to
meet our grandmother our grandmother I hate to
interrupt but we'd like to get you into medical
and debriefing yeah what this way what are you
doing here well someone had to pay for all of
this Tim what have you done are you working
with her now it's complicated I would have
rather stayed down there take us back A lot's
changed in the past two years two years wow
2017 what the hell is going on only everything I
ever promised you oh season 2 supposed to overlap
with king of the monsters I guess Skull Island
research station baby oh that's how they got
Kong over here wow yeah that's how they got Kong
wow [Music] that's cool yeah that's really cool
yeah nice shot that's a really cool tie in I did
wonder how they got Kong yeah that was a question
but Monarch had Kong yeah we'll have to go back
Apex we'll have to go back and do a chronological
rewatch with all 10 episodes of Monarch included
yeah to really understand what's going on Kate
andaro Kate and canaro Tim thank you to Rocket
money for sponsoring this video a brand that
I am happy to be partnered with thrilled to it's
fortunately one that I have been using for quite a
while now prior to ever agreeing to a partnership
with them I was like that makes for the best kind
of synergy promotion because I can actually talk
about them from my heart here reason being like
many you guys of like for years I am constantly
downloading all kinds of financial apps that I
keep forgetting to use or I don't really find
quite as beneficial rocket money has been the
one the only one I'm not just saying it is the
only one that I have been able to consistently use
rely on that has been an absolute game Cher for me
on a very personal note running real rejects is an
absolute privilege however you know like I stress
out about taxes and it's the beginning of the year
and I'm like I'm trying to be smarter and get
it all done now I already started like a couple
months ago getting things in order managing real
rejects finances while managing my own personal
finances has been an ongoing struggle and I'm very
big on like efficiency and being organized but
clearly it wasn't as good enough as I uh thought I
had been so before rocket money came into my life
I was drowning in subscriptions and struggling to
keep track of my expenses and as I really wanted
to like get everything in order rocket money
came at the right time for me I was overwhelmed
with subscriptions I didn't even know I had or
had still been subscribed to I mean do you ever
wonder how many subscriptions you actually pay
for have you ever taken the time to really do it
it could be a little daunting rocket money helped
me see what I was missing and best part they even
canceled those subscriptions for me with just a
simple tap so with rocket money you can have all
your subscriptions in one place making it easy to
cancel anything unnecessary without the hassle of
dealing with customer service my so annoying plus
they'll work on getting you refunds and negotiate
lower bills saving you up to to 20% you just snap
a pick of your bill and let rocket money take care
of the rest let me just summarize for you really
quick what they are they're a personal finance
app that findes and cancels unwanted subscriptions
monitors your spending and helps lower your bills
with over 5 million users and over $500 million in
cancel subscriptions they've already saved members
an average of $720 a year they' helped save me
a little bit more than that don't waste your
hard earn money on unused subscriptions cancel
them today at Rocket money.com rejects that's
rocket money.com rejects if you've heard other
people people talk about them well use ours Rocky
money.com rejects cuz if you use that promo code
rejects you unlock special benefits and yes using
them is also a great way to support the channel
same time it's just a great way to support your
bank account cuz I cannot stress enough just how
much this app has changed the game form me take
control of your finances with rocket money and
enjoy Financial Peace of Mind all righty guys well
if you listening to us on Apple and Spotify please
rate this video and if you're watching us on
YouTube I've got to ask ask why have you not shelv
out your hard-earned dollars and used it to put
into a Shopify account in order to pay for some
real reject merch at reject naations shop.com hey
you know they'd say that when you earn money it's
wise to invest and sometimes investing in yourself
and how you feel and look and also your seventh
or eighth favorite YouTube channel is the best of
Investments to better your mental health to make
you more productive in life and getting any one of
these shirts would do just that for you reation
shop.com thank you to all who have supported us
all right well John just watched Monarch Legacy
of Kaden canaro truly and um I thought that this
was I don't think it's objectively the best
episode I would say it's my I mean you can't
really qualify anything as objective right uh
and this I I I feel like there's parts of my
brain that go no I think the last episode was
the best one I was easily the most emot this is
the first one that got me emotional about [__]
agree you know and it only took like 10 episodes
to get there but I I finally got emotional about
like I found I really felt the emotions here and
this gave me some of my absolute favorite scenes
this might be my favorite I think if you're going
to end the show they ended it strong and it might
be my favorite episode of them all there's like
more of like the sci-fi horror s qualities and
mystery and stuff that looks like other Apple
TV shows I've heard good things about that feel a
little like Westworld that of the last episode I
really love but yeah I was very pulled into this
uh pretty much from beginning to end because I
was actually really invested in the characters
this time and everyone's uh interactions and
Kay and Shaw like their scene work together was
mesmerizing to me it was it was the most dynamic
and the the sadness that had been overcome and
the joy in Shaw's performance but also like the
realization and pain of not realizing oh my God
how much time I've lost in like the amount of
processing and having to survive like there was
there was so much uh multiple layers occurring
throughout each of their performances of like
of course she's relieved to see him but she's
also like so sad and he's just so happy to see her
and he feels like he can finally die and like like
him dying being willing to let go just to keep
her alive just to just to break her out of there
I'm like I believe that that he would let her go
it's a bummer as an audience member I was like
man I was really bummed by that because I wanted
him to give like a big Fu to everyone yeah they
really needed that and Godzilla showed up so you
know it's the best one yeah well he's going to be
back don't worry next season he's coming back
they got to go back and find him yeah I love
how Godzilla just showed up I know like what is
going on did you call my name over here opening
happening here and uh I didn't I didn't authorize
this portal here even there's a bunch of us I just
like to show up at the nick of time that's a good
King right there always aware of what's happening
in his kingdom like let fight we do that's what
we do Titan's fight yeah let them much them all
they want civil not much civility to the Titans
no they're's big animals and just fight yeah
just fight just a ready to rumble fight and eat
and fight world it's a beautiful ready to rumble
world of fantasy yeah yeah exactly we should
all be so lucky you like it kiry clemenson to
make out with with Kate yeah so this show is is
homophobic uh I think because of that uh now I
hated this episode I would agree I would agree
with everything you just said I think yeah the
previous episode is probably I would argue like
the best one in terms of being well-rounded and
having the kind of tonal Intrigue that you would
hope for it makes you want to follow that Rabbit
Hole uh this episode by comparison does have
beats that feel because it's the finale a bit
brief or or kind of rushed or shortlived uh but
I would certainly agree that this had the best
most interesting emotional beats that required
something that sort of like transcends most of
what I associate with the show uh and so yeah
to find ourselves in a couple of scenes having
to process time dilation having to process uh
you know the slowing of age and the passing of
time and and and all this chaos and Madness and
Monarch and Legacy and family like all all the
different layers and shades and just the way that
that they're looking at each other and the way Kay
is like studying his face during their scenes
together because he is different now but still
spiritually the same guy like yeah there was I
think that's why it was great to actually cast
this was when I was like it was so smart to cast
w getting hurt absolutely was because that makes
that exceptionally more believable yeah it's
like I wish this I wish this would have started
in episode nine and like or or gotten there or
or sooner any yeah in its current most current
iteration I wish we started getting those kinds
of moments that made this episode shine at least
in the previous episode because I can understand
being like well you know we'll save K till the
end or something to to finally reunite or whatever
like it's cool to have her do the catniss thing at
the end of the last episode but I feel like that
could have happened at the end of the previous
episode if we finagled a little bit and then
really like I would have loved to have spent
some time just down here with them for a whole
episode and you could have had enough to do with
you feel that loss of like damn how much time have
they lost and you're wondering yeah and never cut
back to Earth because then we don't know and
and that would be pretty interesting and and
I like the twist at the end of like oh man it's
been another two years and and continuing that
emotionality through to her reuniting briefly
with Hiroshi and you know at least getting the
whole like canaro is here too he's your grandson
yeah like all those things yeah like she is just
such a terrific terrific actress and she has been
across this and every moment of hers has typically
brought with it the kind of emotionality and
the kind of impact I think you hope a show like
this could deliver across the boort yeah and uh
yeah like I think that once we start getting to
the point where they're exiting and and things
are happening with Kurt Russell and and you're
drawing him into Jeopardy that's when I start to
feel like the choice itself is appropriate the
execution is good in the moment but feels rushed
over all which is a bummer because when you get
these glimpses of things that are like truly you
just see through the veil and you see the moments
where the show is working ideally and then you're
like okay know you're capable of doing this and
now I wish that you had taken more of that nuance
and flavor and and you know noting the previous
episode some of that sci-fi horror strangeness and
really yeah peppered it through the entire season
because once we finally get to Hollow Earth
like it starts to feel appropriately kind of
expanded and then you think back on the first few
episodes and it just felt like we were spinning
so many Wheels by like running around the world
but saying about bunch of the same dialogue when
we get there and then moving on again yeah uh so
yeah this is like a maddening episode because of
the great qualities of it almost um but yeah you
get your cool Kaiju fight and uh we're home Bob's
your uncle you're requisite Kaiju you're very
very like very requisite didn't need it but you
know you kind of do cuz yeah cuz it's a monarch
it's Legacy of monsters with Godzilla tie in and
just use just have them show up this is literally
the [__] that people complain about in like Star
Wars shows and uh the other franchises you know
marvel whatever when like sure it's just a cameo
it's like an unnecessary Cameo yeah it could have
been any Kaiju who who did this when it happens
you're like what we needed it's weird on the other
shows you're like come on yes it's like cool but
then you're like yeah come on but here on on this
show in particular like well you know you need to
see the monsters it's not like I didn't want to
see Gods it's not like I didn't want to see Kong
you know why wouldn't I want a shot you know yeah
totally why wouldn't I but yeah I think these last
two episodes were undoubtedly the best uh well the
10 one was pretty great but in terms of the show
that I terms of the show that I showed up for I
would I'm like this is uh I think the finale is
my favorite one just on an emotional level and
I even like stuff with Yoshi and canaro and how
complicated that is you know he I like that after
the end of trying to find him just this I I don't
know what the culture is really like I can't
speak to what Society culture is like and it
it just feels like fractured family that it's very
relatable and in in just that uh sense and the and
the fractured part with the with the dad of him
not being able to just let his son in and how how
much of a struggle it is for him because they they
do pay attention I I could still feel the writing
and how they pay attention to the psychology
of the characters like he has a lot of loss
and abandonment issues at the end of the day he
wasn't technically like they didn't like abandon
him purposefully you know but that LE what he
experienced leaves a child feeling abandoned and
it would make sense to me why Hiroshi is the way
he is especially with his son of all people you
know like seeing himself and his son in his own
way and how that also leads to like the divorce
with the mom and how the mom creates a level of
agency and I love the the attention detail too on
her performance of like this level of politeness
that is probably ingrained with her in her culture
but also standing up for herself and making the
right choice for her own kid and this episode
pointing out like hey you know the the legacy of
everything there's uh there's also generational
trauma that occurs and it's about undoing that
now moving forward more than anything else when
Kate said you know this curse is broken and then
everyone in the theater stood up and applauded and
ride that that uh that's what this episode's
about really is is is watching the the shifts
there even with the grandma want K being mean
like I I should like I that was the part though
like I really got it I joke like what's wrong
with this family it it's like I get it you know
like I I would have liked a little bit of an
acknowledgment of yo you're like right here
in front of your granddaughter though you know
like why you interact her a little bit be on
just asking about how's how's your dad you know
well and yeah and like if she's going back what
she just going to say like oh we didn't find her
yeah or is she going to say she decided to stay to
spare your feelings sorry she continued to aband
in you yeah she chose it this time like yeah yeah
she's not she's your granddaughter she's not some
woman and if we had started the emotionality it's
it's like the last two episodes are the yin and
yang of like the second to last episode has all
the the cool all the action oriented stuff and the
tone you want around that is there and then this
episode has all the emotional stuff and the atone
around that is there and if you could just merge
the two because then you know if we had gotten to
here earlier we could have actually lived in that
moment instead of having it be like a quick you
know oh it kind of reminded me of like a dial of
Destiny thing cuz I think the writing is like in
terms of like the actual sci-fi [__] that goes
on in terms of the plot of Monarch is is more
interesting in the last episode like here every
scene with Tim is there's a signal yeah know this
is leading to I'm going to go to canaro there's
a signal going to go to Yoshi there's a signal
that's how so much of the writing on the show
has next next the sign work hey we got him yeah
and and and they're chasing something that we've
already really know the circumstances of yeah so
I did get to a point of like just [__] just act
on the signal just go just do it just spend some
time on something different yeah I'll trade back
my precious Tim time for some better drama that
just watching him spin wheels but the thing is
though is like this the scene workor though be I
I really feel like it's just because of the scene
workor with K and Shaw that alone I'm like I've
never seen so much like I've never felt so much
emotion generated from this show in terms of like
I am really getting in the fields here for what's
happening and I am very much impressed and and
this NE and this scene only exists because of
a Sci-Fi realm you know like it it only works on
the Sci-Fi realm of how like I think that makes
it feel so much more lived in with the drama like
they both seem so believable in this and there's
so much Nuance happening here oh yeah uh it just a
wide pallet of emotions and and and then even when
you get to Hiroshi in her at the end I'm like damn
that is very emotional I don't even like this guy
but I feel for both of them here now and I can see
it's like having Loop you know yeah it's like you
can see all the things that led to all these you
know all of his transgressions laid bare in that
moment and and that you know is is yeah it bridges
that Gap at least in the immediate moment of you
know the stuff about hoshi's character that is
frustrating yeah yeah in that moment it it feels
understandable and you get I feel like the show
has done a relatively mid to poorish job of of
making you see from his perspective because uh
you know just the way they handle the character
for the sake of mystery I don't know it kind of
bungles that but for but in that moment and like
I don't mind a character that we can get intimate
with while watching them make you know difficult
and or you know bad decisions but uh I don't
know yeah it was nice to feel for that here and
to have the emotionality to bolster the logic you
know is true but that isn't the drama of the show
you know I surprisingly came around on a level
of characters I really disliked watching canaro
easily was number one undoubtedly number one and
then I went it it was canaro yeah behind canaro
was Kate behind Kate was kiry Clemens was May
May so went 321 for me like that that was like
kiry Clemens was three canaro didn't just go from
three to what canaro like went like oh my God I
really like canaro now yeah and that and that
through line stayed in this episode I'm like I
really I still really like was in like a oneoff
episod yeah his scenes are good I love it like
the Dynamics are given him are very interesting I
really like him and and like that was probably the
biggest shocker like one episode just slingshotted
like oh my God I actually really I hate you were
like my least favorite people uh and Kate never
really like she had better scenes here but uh Kate
and and may I'm like they they can easily not
return next season they didn't write for them
yeah they they didn't write much of anything
for those characters and I mean like in terms
of like the female characters they did a great
job with K uh like she's the probably the one
of easily the best perform she might be prob the
best character yeah she might be the best terms of
both character and performance and all the stuff
that goes into it uh Cano's mom is great uh who
runs monor she's enjoyable Verdugo yeah she's
enjoyable I think she for for what that role
is she does a qu quality job she's enjoyable when
you put her in a scene with Tim which is all her
scenes yes outside of a couple of scenes that are
not with Tim yeah bad and and I like badass lady
who hasn't been here for a minute yeah yeah she's
fine she's fine um uh but yeah the Kate I did not
really come around to I I I don't feel like they
know how to I liked her scene when she when she
said I'm your granddaughter or something like that
like that was a good emotional moment yeah uh and
and like I said she had better scenes here overall
but I never really came around her character and
I kept trying in my my mind and heart I kept
trying and I just couldn't and uh may she had
that one Apex Tim episode it was weird it was
like a B I thought the way how I was concerned
about my association with canaro that was like
this is just one episode because that's how it
was for May for me I was like Ba's great in this
episode was just the one well and that's that's
so much of what has happened with again it's a
I think a flaw of the show where you will have
these like moments of intense Focus that don't
feel connected to everything else uh cuz I mean
yeah we got a whole episode on Kate and I feel
like the point of doing that was just to somehow
justify this random romance that's now happening
that also doesn't seem to be something they really
care that much about like I'll take detail details
where you don't have to put them over no details
where you don't have to put them but like this
this relationship that they have forming like
one part of my brain is like in theory it's kind
of cool that I guess this romance can just kind
of happen and it's just like a little thing they
keep peppering in with like body language or like
little gestures but at the same time it also feels
like it's just sort of like a happen stance that
it made it in here like you're I don't know like
life can feel like happens dance but when you're
making art or Cinema or a show or whatever you
got to put a lot of thought into that and I feel
like there was little to no thought put into
that so it's one of those it doesn't make me
mad because again these are madeup characters that
can do whatever they want but at the same time it
does feel like one of those things where it's like
this is a cool choice to have made could you could
you focus on or maybe pepper it with anything
could you give me anything to care about with
this because you know they've been brought
together maybe was the character who like I
don't even want to be I don't want to be brought
on this Advent she was kind of like just along
for the ride at the beginning of the journey MH
and like there experiences again I I always just
think back to that one moment where they're in the
cave and Kate's having that uh PTSD moment in like
episode three or whatever when they're exploring
the radiation Zone uh and like that is about the
only moment I could think of that like is intimate
between them for any reason and now they have this
whole like unspoken thing which again is like
like it's cool in isolation but it's not really
it doesn't feel like it's been made part of those
characters and it feels like the most significant
thing that's happened to Kate in recent aside from
being a sidekick on the Lee Shaw Adventure is this
romance and it feels like this sort of weird just
I don't know additional addendum they just like
taped to the side yeah or something like that and
her performances again it's like I don't even even
really feel I don't know what it is cuz I don't
feel like it's the actor again but I can also feel
like in those moments in this episode that we more
emotional like even the way they're shooting her
isn't that intimate the dialogue that they give
her the scenes they give her aren't that prolonged
or in depth or anything so I just feel like the
show treated her with such a pedestrian gaze and
never really except for that one episode again and
except for the early moments of the PTSD cutting
in like even that trailed off and doesn't really
feel like part of her charact she's just like
peppy now and that's fine but she doesn't really
feel like an actual character no but overall um
I don't know what I'd give this show out of 10
I'll give it a uh 70% for Goodwill give it a like
a 6.8 sure why not I don't give [__] 6 point I
like the finale it's great all right solid finale
overall uh what do you guys think of Monarch you
want to season two what would you want to explore
I actually feel like there'd be more personality
if Apex was here the whole time sure just because
I love the silly ass cheese it brings um leave
your thoughts down below subscribe leave a like
and let's end this with a p Brian Perry it's 2024
we've entered the dawn of shout outs for Brian
Perry and now we got to kick it off properly with
figuring out what your New Year's resolution is
going to be this year my friend and I feel like
your New Year's resolution will be to make your
bed every morning oh it's a good one it's a great
one I think making your bed every morning clears
your mind helps you feel like you accomplish a
task for the day and if I know you Brian Perry
and I think I do you probably sleep in the nude
yes and when you sleep in the nude sometimes as
a guy I get it you're probably really hairy might
leave a little bit of a mark uhoh little brown
Mark silhouette just in little hairs or that or a
poop mark yeah poop mark yeah I went first you got
a yes s so poop Mark was there poop mark with hair
on it poop mark with hair on it and when you make
your bed you can cover that [__] up literally
you can and then no one will notice was there
and I've been like dude maybe your resolution
this year should be to buy some brown sheets
some Black Sheets maybe the uh crystaline White
is not really cutting for you and maybe not even
a fabric maybe some kind of vinyl you know yeah
and then next year 2025 you can buy some better
toilet paper in a bedet three my friend that might
work as well so um you're the second Patron I have
made a poop reference to and I feel like it's
going to be an ongoing theme now it's the poop
month for sh what creative way will you poop so
Brian my friend uh make your bed every morning
uh seriously it'll help uh uh Free Your Mind of
a of a lot of of a lot of uh you know people say
it does something for you it's a placebo effect
it's a bunch of [__] it's like writing your
name on the paper to get points a it's not really
going to do anything it's like when you add some
[__] onto your to-do list to make you feel
like oh wow I'm ahead of the day some people
say you shouldn't even make your bed cuz it's
going to move all the particulates around and
attract bed bugs and things like that you should
just leave it that's why John has bed [Music] bugs